[Música]
en primer lugar agradecer
a ustedes por creer todavía en la
educación y contarles que me han
invitado a hablar de educación pero como
yo soy porfiaba dije no pienso hablar de
educación voy a hablar de ornitología
ornitología que es eso ustedes lo saben
verdad me imagino es el estudio
científico del reino de las aves y
elegido dos aves citas para que
conversemos y
ambas viven en chile viven en otros
lugares del planeta también pero las
tenemos en chile en los bosques
lluviosos del sur tenemos el pájaro
carpintero también llamado pica maderas
este pájaro tiene un tamaño un poquito
mayor de medio metro de envergadura y
tiene un solo objetivo en la vida que es
taladrar
como taladran los carpinteros a ver
hagamos el ruido de los carpinteros
taladrando toc toc toc toc toc toc toc
verdad eso es así se la pasan y que
taladra la dura corteza de los árboles
para que para extraer de allí su
alimento porque es un ave insectívora
pero también les quiero hablar de este
pequeño ave cita 12 de estas aves y
estás hacen un pájaro carpintero es una
visita muy pequeña
colibrí y es completamente diferente su
vida es volar volar a una velocidad
mueve su salita de una manera de una
velocidad impresionante con una veloz
impresionante
es casi ingrávido es de una sutileza de
una suavidad de un silencio y a través
de esta ingravidez llega entonces al
corazón de la flor
tenemos por un lado este pájaro
taladrante y tenemos por otro lado este
pájaro silencioso sutil y grácil
tendrá esto que ver con la educación ya
vamos a entrar a hablar de educación
cada cierto tiempo se ponen de moda
ciertos temas en educación y es así como
después de howard gardner en 1980 se
puso de moda se acuerdan ustedes las
'inteligencias múltiples' verdad y
trabajamos sobre inteligencias múltiples
hablamos de los talentos de los niños
pero en el último tiempo se ha puesto de
moda la inteligencia emocional y se ha
puesto de moda la educación emocional es
decir para que alguien y ella ser
inteligente emocional hay que educarlo
emocionalmente y que es educarlo
obviamente a quien vamos a educar a los
niños y educarlos emocionalmente
significa que ellos aprendan a reconocer
a identificar sus emociones a
gestionarlas de manera adecuada de modo
de poder establecer interacciones
exitosas que a nivel escolar se le llama
buena convivencia buen trato y a nivel
de la casa se le llama buen
comportamiento gentileza buenos modales
buena educación etcétera etcétera eso
sería la educación emocional
quienes deben hacer educación emocional
quienes son los educadores los padres
los cuidadores las nanas indudablemente
y en la escuela todo el equipo que
trabaja allí especialmente el profesor
de aula hoy día la educación emocional
parece estar en crisis nadie lo dudaría
y entonces se produce hay una discusión
entre los adultos y los niños los
adultos dicen nosotros llevamos años
haciendo educación emocional el dilema
está en que no nos resulta y porque no
nos resulta porque los niños de hoy día
están imposibles son rebeldes
oposicionistas algunos desafiantes mal
educados gara bateros desafiantes a
morir transgresores cuando son
adolescentes es decir queremos hacer
educación emocional y ya no nos resulta
ya no nos resulta y los chicos dicen por
el contrario
nadie está haciendo educación emocional
con nosotros como es posible
veamos qué está pasando quién tiene la
razón los adultos son los niños quién
cree en ustedes los adultos o los niños
los niños por qué razón por qué los
adultos estamos haciendo educación
emocional de una manera equivocada y de
qué manera equivocada estamos haciendo
la educación emocional los adultos hemos
adoptado el papel de pájaro carpintero y
entonces como buen pájaro carpintero
hemos elegido la corteza que creemos más
dura cual es la corteza cerebral de
quién es de nuestros niños y qué hacemos
con esta corteza son un pájaro
carpintero por lo tanto toc toc toc toc
toc taladra mos la corteza cerebral de
nuestros chicos de qué manera
reprimendas retos amenazas gritos
humillaciones más de algunas
descalificaciones para que quien no se
puede esperar nada de ti
y creemos que de esa manera nos vamos a
guiar por la buena senda
entonces como vemos acá allí está la
corteza el pájaro carpintero
esa es la que elegimos y que vamos a
hacer sobre ella vamos a taladrar y nos
pasamos años taladrando comenzamos
cuando son muy pequeñitos y taladra amos
y taladra moss y tala gramos porque
porque nosotros intuitivamente o
instintivamente sabemos que aquí está la
corteza y debajo está el mundo emocional
y es el mundo emocional el que genera
desafíos y transgresión oposicionismo
etcétera etcétera
por lo tanto usamos la corteza para
llegar al mundo emocional taladrando la
corteza y que los chicos comiencen a
portarse bien
y así como decía un niño que muy mal
portado les decía menos mal que ya no me
castigan mandándome a la inspectoría no
le digo yo y como te castigan ahora me
mandan al departamento de buena
convivencia
y ahí eso cambia las cosas no me
castigan igual me pasó castigaban buena
convivencia no bueno el tema pasa porque
nosotros estamos haciendo un camino lo
vamos a ir en inglés no porque sea muy
elegante sino que porque es lo que se
usa decirlo top-down desde la corteza
bajamos entonces a al mundo emocional y
esperamos por lo tanto que las cosas
anden bien y cuál es nuestro sistema de
taladro ya lo dije primero el reto la
reprimenda el sermón no hay nada más
taladrante que el sermón y luego pasamos
a acciones mayores como gritar amenazar
castigar y dentro del castigo está
también el castigo físico
será cierto somos así somos tan pájaros
carpinteros preguntémosle a los niños y
les vamos a preguntar a los niños
chilenos esta encuesta se ha hecho
también en uruguay en mexico en perú en
fin que dijeron los niños chilenos el
71% de ellos consideró que tanto en casa
como en la escuela se taladraban sus
cortezas cerebrales pero no lo dijeron
de esa manera tan elegante que dijeron
me maltratan y cuando le preguntaron y
qué es el maltrato para ti me gritan me
pegan me retan me sermonean me tironean
las orejas me pegan una palmada etcétera
etcétera 71% de los niños chilenos esto
es una cifra bien alarmante verdad o sea
nos deja como pájaros carpinteros pero
más alarmante todavía es que cuando les
preguntaron y eso te parece bien o mal
el 50 por ciento de estos chicos dijo
está muy bien porque de esta manera me
están educando
y cuando un chico a los 9 a los 10 años
estima que está correcta una determinada
técnica educativa como es el maltrato es
porque cuando sea adulto que va a ser
maltratador y entonces tenemos un
sistema transgeneracional que se empieza
a repetir en el cual es creemos que
estamos haciendo las cosas bien quiénes
son los que se les maltrata más
entendiendo que no es sólo maltrato
físico no es el grito es la amenaza es
la palmada también a quienes los más
grandes un papá dijo bueno qué importa
si esté cabra ya tiene 12 años un tirón
de oreja le va a ser bien ocurre que en
chile el 75 por ciento de los padres de
niños menores de 5 años reconoce usar
estos métodos para enseñarles educación
emocional el 75 por ciento es decir se
libra uno de cuatro
ahora esto podría ser inocente la verdad
es que como dice alguien por ahí la
vecina se fija en la vecina que sale va
arregla a barrer la vereda siempre es la
que sabe lo máximo en educación
bueno la vecina que barre la vereda dice
también una buena cachetada o bien te
ven cuando le hace muy bien el problema
que no es inocente porque porque nuestro
organismo tiene un sistema que tiene un
nombre encantador este nombre encantador
es sistema simpático han visto a alguien
que es rico ya uno le digan simpático
verdad el dilema que este sistema
simpático que en condiciones normales
como estamos nosotros acá funciona muy
bien porque nos mantiene en vigilia en
alerta cuando arrecia el pájaro
carpintero taladrando la corteza
cerebral
este sistema simpático se activa y al
activarse qué ocurre se produce una
respuesta hiper activada y el niño
entonces
te pasa esto huída no tengo miedo de mi
mamá o desafío que se imagina este
profesor que me golpea la mesa y me
grita no le hago caso y como ven ustedes
transgresión así que no es tan fácil así
que podemos hacer obviamente los chicos
tienen la razón no estamos haciendo una
buena educación emocional pero no
tenemos otra que uno dice mira la forma
que tú haces usas empleas les entra por
acá y les sale por acá ya pero no tiene
más de dos orejas de niñito si tiene
otra tiene una tercera oreja y esta
tercera oreja es una pequeña oreja y
como se dice pequeña oreja en latín en
latín se dice aurícula y entonces la
pregunta es dónde tenemos una aurícula
mi corazón tenemos 2 la derecha y la
izquierda y tenemos dos ventrículos
también ya bueno entre la aurícula
derecha y el ventrículo derecho tenemos
un cerebro un cerebro y esa es la
pequeña tercera oreja este cerebro ahí
lo vemos es pequeñísimo tiene alrededor
de 45 mil neuronas pero es maravilloso
porque porque reúne información de todo
el organismo captada a través de un
nervio que tiene un nombre terrible así
como el otro se llamaba sistema
simpático este se llama nervio vago está
algo peor que llamarse vago yo le
llamaría niña y para que no se nos dé
tanta verdad bueno este nervio vago
recoge información de todo el organismo
y la lleva a este corazón y este corazón
que hace procesa la información de un
modo tal que no hay ningún sistema del
organismo que use este sistema de
procesamiento de información es un
procesamiento en modo sabiduría es un
procesamiento en modo intuición y es un
procesamiento en modo clarividencia
así que si ustedes no lo sabían yo se
los digo hoy día todos ustedes son
clarividentes pero para eso tienen que
aprender a usar este corazón este
cerebro adentro del corazón procesa la
información y la manda ahora al sistema
cerebral a donde al mundo emocional que
está debajo de la corteza en el mundo
emocional se serena todo se producen
fenómenos emociones increíbles sosiego
certeza confianza estima pertenencia
seguridad y una vez que las emociones se
procesan de esa manera entonces se
mandan hacia arriba por lo tanto este es
un sistema bottom up de abajo hacia
arriba del corazón hacia está bueno
podemos entonces cambiar si cuál es la
invitación la invitación es pongámonos
en modo pájaro colibrí brasil ingrávido
pequeño silencioso aprendamos a escuchar
prestemos atención plena a lo que está
ocurriendo con los niños cuando se están
portando mal cuando están con problemas
conductuales atención plena porque será
este problema de conducta miremos los
con dulzura aunque tengamos ganas de
hacer esto verdad
hablemos les dulcemente porque esos son
los recursos que tú puedes usar para
abrir esta puerta y llegar acá cuando tú
usas esos recursos entonces abres la
puerta de acá viaja hacia la corteza
cerebral y todo se resuelve y el niño
que le pasa al niño a los niños a la
conjunto de los niños en un aula se
serenan y se mueve se ponen en modo
confianza seguridad
estima se sienten estimados pero por su
profesor el profe me quiere mi papá me
quiere no como los niños dicen hoy día
depende si me quiere o no pero como como
depende que te quiera si me sacó buenas
notas me quiere y la mamá que quiere
depende de qué depende de que me porté
bien no sé este niño se va a sentir
certeramente querido y tratado
dignamente la clave acá si ustedes la
ven
no sé si está por ahí es el respeto allá
está como te acercas a esta oreja del
corazón está esta oreja del corazón que
en el fondo es un cerebro increíble como
les digo tú te vas a acercar de una
manera muy particular y aquí está esta
es la invitación como me puedo
transformar en un colibrí con respeto
presta atención plena
muestra interés genuino por lo que está
ocurriendo con los niños hoy día la
crianza es distraída estamos con el
celular y al alrededor nuestro están
ocurriendo verdaderos desastres y cuando
nos fijamos que están los desastres que
hacemos ya los castigados tú para tu
pieza tu pieza pasa en el celular verdad
y no hemos prestado atención que más
vamos a hacer empatía ponernos en el
lugar del niño porque nosotros somos
adultos pero ellos no y finalmente
sensibilidad a las necesidades de los
niños
si lográramos y esto es una lucha que
estamos dando constantemente desde el
modelo que yo trabajo aquí es el modelo
del cerebro en desarrollo si lográramos
aprender a ponernos en modo colibrí
cuando queremos hacer educación
emocional estaríamos logrando lo que
creemos imposible y se los doy firmados
no se logra los niños responden pero
además lograríamos algo mejor todavía
que es cambiar la consigna
transgeneracional los niños ya no dirían
me pegan porque me están educando dirían
me tratan amorosamente porque me están
educando verdad y sin darnos cuenta
estaríamos construyendo el sueño de
todos quienes trabajamos en educación
que no es obviamente estaba usted lo
están pensando
no es la psv - ahora verdad el sueño de
todos los que trabajamos en educación es
aportar a la construcción de un mundo de
paz y de no violencia eso es la
educación no es lograr que los chicos se
preparen para tener un buen trabajo y
que saquen excelentes notas
formar buenas personas y que son las
buenas personas las buenas personas son
personas de buen corazón
a transformarnos en colibríes salgan
todo volando por aquí por favor muchas
gracias
muchas
[Aplausos]
[Música]